la vraie compétition c'est la
compétition sexuelle et celle-là il y a
pas d'égalité possible en plus ben non
vous savez quand on ne bouge pas par le
jingle vous êtes au courant
je suis pas mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais faire une interview fin du monde
comme vous êtes quelqu'un de
spécialement gay comme on vient de le
voir je vais faire
une interview fin du monde alors c'est
la fin du monde Michel oui les corbeaux
c'est la fin du monde si vous deviez
sauver un livre moi je prendrai la Bible
parce que bon c'est pas abouti
mais on peut en refaire plein à partir
de la Bible donc c'est très générateur
quoi il y a plein de petites histoires
on peut déjà beaucoup servi pour refaire
des livres à partir de si vous deviez
sauver un animal le bichon frisé le
bichon frisé oui vous aimez les bichons
frisés oui c'est magnifique
et c'est comme c'est un tout petit chien
c'est comme une peluche c'est tout
gentil
non non ça boit pas beaucoup non presque
pas
c'est hyper gentil
si vous deviez sauver une idée une idée
hausse je vais être un peu chiant c'est
peut-être l'idée de la preuve
mathématique ça c'est bien ça a beaucoup
servi c'est un peu chiant question
suivante un disque
il y en a trop le vôtre non non
Beethoven c'est mieux
un film peut-être murno l'horreur
si vous aviez sauvé un sexe
moi je dirais le tabac ça a l'air de
rien mais c'est bien si vous deviez
sauver un homme politique ça serait qui
je sais pas j'ai rien contre
honnêtement j'aime bien Chevènement mais
désolé pour le public
mais non j'aime bien Chevènement
Chevènement ah ouais ouais je trouve
qu'il est courageux qui l'a sauvé une
fois
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu